[Musique]
selon les médias polonais est notre
invité politique ce matin c'est frédéric
valletoux bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous vous êtes le maire de
fontainebleau membres d'agir président
de la fédération hospitalière de france
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse quotidienne régionale représenté
par fabrice les serres dont des journaux
du groupe ebra vaujour fabrice les
journaux régionaux de l'est de la france
on le précise plus on commence par la
crise sanitaire a bien sûr frédéric
valletoux on attend toujours la décision
de l'exécutif un jean castex a beaucoup
beaucoup consulté hier et selon gabriel
ateliers un consensus politique qui se
dégage autour du fait qu'il faut des
mesures plus restrictives
est ce que pour vous un confinement est
désormais inéluctable oui je pense
les modalités on les connaîtra dans
quelques jours mais quand on regarde les
chiffres les indicateurs sanitaires
lorsqu'on regarde la pression sur les
hôpitaux on peut pas souhaiter autre
chose que des mesures renforcées hors
des mesures renforcées ça s'appelle un
confinement on est déjà dans un
couvre-feu qui démarre en fin d'après
midi
on peut difficilement à alléger dire au
delà sans aller vers un confinement donc
oui je pense que c'est nécessaire on a
jusqu'à présent tenu parce qu'on a
toujours veillé en tout cas ça a été
tout le ska souhaitait le gouvernement
depuis bientôt un an depuis février
dernier février mars dernier c'était de
faire attention à ne pas ce que
l'hôpital soit pas débordé et que la
pression soit leur contenu sur les
lignes hospitalière là on voit qu'on est
à un niveau qui est très très élevé on a
presque trente mille patients qui
développent des formes graves de cofide
à l'hôpital c'est un niveau très élevé
depuis des semaines et on sait que s'il
va s'accroître parce que l'épidémie
continue en a heureusement pas revenir
longuement sur la situation de l'hôpital
mais pour rester sur ce confinement
fabriquent souvent on a en a maintenant
un petit peu d'expérience en matière de
confinement hélas et vous tromperez
hospitalier
vous avez quand même une idée du
confinement le plus adapté en réalité
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire c'est plutôt
du confinement du ravec fermeture des
écoles des commerces
quand finalement adapté le confinement
le plus adapté c'est celui qui limite le
plus les interactions sociales qui fait
qu'on se croise le moins possible c'est
à dire qu'on ferme loin abel non mais
après évidemment une fois qu'on a dit ça
on a la foi pas dit grand-chose monde a
quand même posé un principe comme ce qui
est intéressant c'est vous avez la
double casquette de à la fois président
de la fédération hospitalière et de mère
vous êtes un petit peu sur tous les
aspects mais quel est le bon équilibre
pour vous est ce que vous dites
maintenant la seule solution c'est un
confinement dur je pense
qu'effectivement il n'a pas fait tout ça
pour rien et que s'il faut passer par
quelques semaines d'un confinement qui
ressemble plus à celui du printemps que
à celui du mois d'octobre
alors allons-y allons-y de manière très
claire
allons-y parce qu on est aussi dans une
course de vitesse avec les vaccins et on
parlera peut-être des difficultés
d'approvisionnement de des vaccins mais
néanmoins on est dans cette campagne
vaccinale qui nous apporte un espoir
donc il nous reste quand même je dire
quelques mois à tenir quelques mois à
contenir ce virus quelques mois anneux
pour ne pas se faire déborder et et bien
sûr dans ma ville j'ai plus de 500
commerces
je sais à quel point c'est compliqué
pour les
les commerces à quel point cette année a
été terrible et difficile que les
restaurants n'ont toujours pas réouvert
et je sais la difficulté économique et
je mesure les la difficulté aussi
psychologique pour certaines personnes
mais néanmoins j'ai dit on a réussi pour
l'instant quand on se compare à d'autres
a plutôt contenir l'épidémie et
finalement elle a été moqué à plusieurs
reprises elle est insatisfaisante
elle a était insatisfaisante à plusieurs
reprises aussi on l'a pointé cette
stratégie de l'état on n'a sans doute
pas assez isolé les patients l'avant il
ya beaucoup de choses qui ont été dites
et et qui a à dire mais néanmoins quand
on se l est pas si mauvaise que ça elle
a montré qu'elle s'adapte et donc là je
pense qu'effectivement il faut trouver
les moyens de faire en sorte que l'on ne
soit pas débordé on est vraiment sur des
chiffres et des perspectives qui sont
assez alarmantes sur le front sanitaires
frédéric valletoux vous évoquez la
vaccination
vous pensez vous avez espoir que la
vaccination telle qu'elle est conçue
aujourd'hui malgré l'arrivée des
variants dont on n'a pas tous les
tenants et les aboutissants vous pensez
réellement que la vaccination sera
efficace écoutez je suis pas médecin je
fais confiance dans le corps médical
on lit on voit des études qui
effectivement nous disent qu'ils
viennent d'israël qui viennent d'autres
pays qui nous disent que finalement la
vaccination est là son effet en israël
la vaccination telle qu'elle a été faite
elle a permis de faire chuter de 60%
le nombre de personnes âgées qui vont à
l'hôpital et qui développent des formes
graves donc on voit bien que je suis pas
si ça sera le passage mais la solution
miracle le vaccin mais je sais une voie
de sortie échos hausse face à ce virus
je ne vais pas dire qu'on apprend en
marchant mais en tout cas on s'adapte au
fur et à mesure effectivement de ce que
la science nous dit de ce que les
enquêtes épidémiologiques nous révèle de
ce que l'on apprend au fil du temps de
2,2 de ce virus
donc oui je pense que la vaccination
c'est une voie de sortie on a des
difficultés d'approvisionnement il faut
là aussi peut sans doute accepter que
cette campagne de vaccination s'étale
sur plus de semaines ou de mois qu'on
imaginait au départ due au manque de
doses duo difficultés
d'approvisionnement dues à la tension
mondiale due au fait que tout le monde
cherche des vaccins tout le monde en
veut tout le monde en achète que nous on
est passé par une voix européenne bon
qui a sans doute des avantages mais qui
a aussi cette contrainte qu'on est
dépendant de contrats et de discussion
qui finalement quelque part nous échappe
au niveau français mais au moins on est
dans une solidarité européenne et j'ai
visionné fallait passer par là et les
malheurs d'approvisionnement que l'on
connaît on va tous les pays européens la
connaissent aussi donc mais que ça des
conséquences est ce qu'aujourd'hui en
tant que mère est toujours en tant que
président la fédération hospitalière
vous savez
ce qu'il en est est ce que par exemple
une personne qui veut se faire vacciner
pour un premier rendez vous est ce que
c'est encore possible aujourd'hui
alors c'est encore possible à condition
d'attendre c'est-à-dire c'est encore
possible bien sûr c'est possible mais
les acquis ce rendez vous laisserons pas
bloquer les prises de rendez-vous sont
bloqués pour le mois de février et fin
février début mars oui alors on va donc
en tout le mois de février impossible de
prendre un premier rendez vous selon vos
infos là maintenant en tout cas chez moi
c'est plus fins et plus possible parce
que entre laissez vous conter à
fontainebleau et d'incendié de france au
cégep ont affronté à l'ordre de juger
par leur remontée de toute l'île de
france
mais si aujourd'hui c'est bloqué parce
que fut entre les premiers rendez-vous
qui sont d'ores et déjà calé et les
rappels qui ont été calées au moment de
la premier du premier du premier vaccin
le mois de février est blindé donc c'est
vrai que les difficultés
d'approvisionnement font qu'on
constatera qu'en février
très peu de premières vaccinations pu
être faite et que finalement février
sera surtout des semaines pendant
lesquelles on vaccinera en laura bei m 2
en deuxième dose donc c'est
insatisfaisant de ce point de vue là
très clairement
surtout qu'en plus ça y est ouvert tous
les maires au ciemi enfin tous les
maires il ya plein de santé à 1200
centre qui ont ouvert en france ils
fonctionnent tous la médecine libérale
s'est mobilisé les infirmiers
infirmières médecins libéraux
généralistes sont là pour faire tourner
les centres avec les hôpitaux tout près
parce qu'un tiers des décès sans tourner
aussi avec l'appui des des hôpitaux donc
la logistique
elle a enfin démarré on met ça veut dire
clairement que le gouvernement qui à un
moment nous disait on va ouvrir la
vaccination pour les personnes de plus
de 65 ans au mois de février
ça on n'y compte pas le mois de février
ça sera toujours réservé aux plus de 75
ans non le mois de février ce sera au
lait + 75 ans je vois pas comment avant
fin mars on peut imaginer fin mars pour
vous l'ouverture plus de 65 ans
sauf à ce que miraculeusement tout d'un
coup arrive d'aider y pleuvent des doses
de vaccin sur la france mais j'y crois
pas trop
hook est en tout cas qui les
approvisionnements plus important mais
je pense que le raisonnablement oui les
plus de 65 ans faudra viser faudra viser
fin mars
donc c'est une raison supplémentaire
pour vous d'aller vers un confinement
plus strictes oui c'est une raison pour
revenir à votre question initiale où
effectivement c'est une raison qui doit
nous conduire à aller vers un
confinement plus strictes après il ya
des questions qui sont très difficiles
très délicate sur lequel je me garderai
bien me prononcer super spécialistes
vis-à-vis des enfants vis vis des écoles
comme voilà est-ce que c'est pour tout
tous les territoires et ce qu'il faut
graduée aussi selon l'intensité dans
certains territoires
bon il ya ya ya enfin je mesure
réellement la difficulté pour le
gouvernement d'arriver à imposer des
règles là où effectivement il ya des
enjeux derrière qu'on méprise mieux
maintenant notamment les retombées
économiques psychologiques
les retombées pour les enfants au mois
de mars on l'était dans l'inconnu et la
sidération
on y est allé et on a respecté tous ses
entrées et tout le monde d'être partagée
7,7 cette nécessité de confinement
aujourd'hui c'est plus compliqué on va
parler de la situation des hôpitaux mais
d'abord les maires les maires qui qu'on
a entendu les maires et les élus locaux
d'ailleurs plus généralement qu'on a
entendu dire on n'est pas assez écoutée
on n'est pas assez associé jean castex a
reçu hier les présidents d'associations
d'élus est ce que vous dites bon là on
est quand même plus entendu est ce que
ça se passe mieux à ce niveau là mais il
était temps alors c'est bon il ya
toujours eu un des visio avec des
associations d'élus
bon mais disons qu'on nous informait on
disait voilà ça va se passer comme ça
j'ai l'impression que j'étais pas hier
dans le dialogue et hume et des retours
que j'ai ça a été il ya eu une vraie
discussion est ce qu'elle va peser sur
les choses
est ce que la vie des uns et des autres
va peser sur les décisions une fine et
qui vont être prises
ça on le saura dans quelques jours mais
mais néanmoins il ya ça n'a pas été la
litanie des décisions qui allaient
arriver ça a été plutôt une discussion
et ça se dit donc plutôt positif pense
que oui dans les choses qu'on qu'il faut
garder de des réussites de cette de ce
qu'on vit de cette épidémie
il ya quand même la formidable capacité
de mobilisation de réaction des maires
on l'a vu à l'époque des masques on l'a
vu à l'époque des tests au moment des
tests on a vu tout ce qui a été fait par
les collectivités locales
donc on le voit aujourd'hui avec cette
capacité en quelques jours puisque chez
moi mais donc pour les 1200 centre qui
ont ouvert ça s'est passé en quelques
jours jusqu'à noël on nous a dit surtout
pas de vaccinodromes c'est pas la
stratégie que qu'on souhaite
et puis entre noël et jour de l'an on
l'a dit pas finalement on va ouvrir des
centres de vie alors on les a pas
appelés vaccineront pour pas avoir l'air
de changer de pied complètement
enfin nous allons quand même demandé
d'ouvrir des gymnases et des salles
municipales points bons dont acte on l'a
fait en dix jours c'est est prêt on a su
mobiliser les forces médical de nos de
nos villes pour être partie prenante de
l'aventuré on s'est appuyé sur les
hôpitaux là où il y en avait été
finalement aujourd'hui sa tombe donc les
mères c'est vraiment un élément qui est
un pas négliger il a été pendant des
mois et des mois lors de la première
phase de la delà de la de l'épidémie bon
aujourd'hui je pense qu'ils ont montré
qu'ils étaient incontournables
jean castex que vous connaissez plus
longtemps vous êtes issu de la même
famille politique
oui c'est l'homme de la situation
c'est en tout cas je crois qu'ils les
gie avec pragmatisme et il agit en
connaissant bien le monde de la santé
qu'il agit en connaissant bien les les
les territoires voilà je pense qu'il
faut faire preuve de fonds lui
reconnaître une humilité une envie
d'avancer en écoutant les uns les autres
l'homme de la situation je pense que il
ya enfin clairement il n'y a pas d'homme
de la situation particulièrement c'est
une capacité à écouter à fédérer à et
surtout à faire de la pédagogie
bon je pense qu on a eu deux premiers
ministres successifs edouard philippe
avait ses qualités là aussi il était
maire il était pédagogue on retrouve ses
qualités lâché jean castex
on va parler de la situation des
hôpitaux avons-nous disais tout à
l'heure les chiffres sont alarmants de
quelques chiffres et si vous disposez
vous pouvez vous pouvez me donner ce
matin les chiffres c'est les chiffres
que l'on connaît je veux donner qu'un
c'est les près de trente mille patients
qu'aux vide qui sont aujourd'hui à
l'hôpital
je rappelle que quand on a confiné au
moins de mars mi mars
il y avait trois un peu plus de 3000
patients qu'ovide à l'hôpital alors
certes il y avait des projections qui
montré que si on faisait rien c'était
pas 3000 mais c'était dix fois peut-être
qu'un soit plus ce qui allait arriver et
on a agi aujourd'hui on a des scénarios
qui peuvent nous emmener
assez assez loin et assez haut mais on
part d'une base qu'il donne au scénario
aujourd'hui c'est pas mes scénarios
s'est laissée dans les scénarios dont
vous disposez c'est un pic un pic à kehl
semaine qu'à l'échéance c'est je ne veux
pas donner de chiffres parce que les
scénarios et notamment institut pasteur
est très prudent et dans les scénarios
que l'on lit a toujours trois hypothèses
et il se garde bien de dire avec
certitude on va vers là mais on voit
quand même qu'on a une tendance qui quoi
qu'il arrive sur ces trois hypothèses
qui sont décrites sont quand même des
hypothèses qui vont amener forcément
plus de gens à l'hôpital
les variants où il ya une enquête flash
qui a démarré hier on aura les premiers
résultats ce week end encore en seniors
ces résistances que représentent les
variantes dans le nombre de deux roues
nassif qui est sorti il ya quelques
jours qui dit que 10 % des nouveaux cas
en ile de france sont des cas du variant
onglets ou est-ce que sur toutes les
territoires de france on est sur la même
proportion ce qui serait énorme
on le sera ce week-end ou lundi lorsque
le cette enquête flash qui portent quand
même sur deux cent mille analyse qui
vont être faites qui ont été faites va
nous permettre de révéler la situation
on sait aussi simplement que de manière
mécanique à partir moment où plus de
personnes vont être touchées par le
virus dans les semaines qui viennent du
fait de ces variants qui sont plus
contagieux on aura mécaniquement plus de
monde à l'hôpital il faut regarder le
poids global de faim le volume global
plutôt de ses patients sur l'hôpital
parce que quand on regarde simplement le
chiffre des réanimations effectivement
on pourrait dire bah oui on est à la
moitié des lits de réanimation 56% alors
c'est tout les réanimations covin ne
sont pas
toutes les réanimations c'est à dire le
on a les sourcils des animations kovy
oui mais ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on sait qu'un patient qui
développe les symptômes aigus
on le met pas forcément réanimation on a
la prise en charge nations qui n'ont pas
forcément le côté bien sûr sur rai taux
de saturation des réanimations à l'ocré
taux de saturation des rades des
réanimations on a montré qu'on était
capable d eau pillé des hôpitaux étaient
capables d'ouvrir des lits de
réanimation assez rapidement à partir du
moment où ils en avaient besoin mais
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui la moitié à
peu près des lits de réanimation
un peu plus de la moitié sont des
occupés par des patients qu'ovide bon de
réanimation aujourd'hui pour être
différent avait promis plus de lits de
réanimation pendant la première vague
est ce que la promesse a été tenue
combien on a dit alors qu'on a
aujourd'hui 5000 un peu plus 5000 lits
de réanimation aux mêmes capacités et
c'est la même chose que il ya un an
avant de la lever mis sa patte mais pas
plus pas moins
parfum pas plus on peut on ouvrir plus
après la question c'est de manière
pérenne on a toujours 5000 lits de
réanimation
s'il ya des besoins de base et si par
malheur on a besoin d'en ouvrir trois à
quatre mille en plus on a montré qu'on
l'avait fait en mars avril on leur fera
dans les semaines qui viennent
après la question c'est que ces dix là
supplémentaires n'ont pas été pérennisé
pour une raison simple c'est que ces
lits supplémentaires de ranimation il
tourne avec du personnel qui à qui on a
ce qu'on affecte à ses services de
réanimation mais qui ne sont pas des
personnels de réanimation dans l'urgence
je vais pas parler de médecine de guerre
mais dans l'urgence
vous prenez des personnels ici ou là
vous expliquer en quelques jours comment
fonctionne un respirateur artificiel
et puis vous le vous balancer des
gendres gueule entre guillemets vous
affecter les gens à des services de
réanimation d'eau effectivement mais
c'est pas des organisations
effectivement ça peut marcher mais c'est
pas des organisations durable à venir
frédéric valletoux si je vous suis on
n'a plus de moyens matériels mais pas
plus de moyens humains
aujourd'hui mais c'est par rapport au
premier comprimé à la preuve mon projet
inique mais la réalité l'hôpital c'est
de fait qu'effectivement on manque de
personnel
nous on a manqué avant la crise et on en
manque toujours aujourd'hui c'est à dire
que d'abord parce qu'on crée pas des
médecins des infirmiers comme ça en
quelques mois donc il ya pas de
génération spontanée qui arrivent mais
surtout
ça reste ça reste la grande faiblesse
alors les accords de figure ont rendu
plus attractives les les professions les
rémunérations à l'hôpital mais le temps
que cela se fasse son effet que les
jeunes générations et envie de
s'investir plus dans ces métiers
conforme et serra qu'on relance un peu
l'attractivité des métiers
il va se passer quelques années donc
dans l'urgence on peut faire face à un
pic parce qu'ils ont des programmes ont
vite certains secteurs est et et on
affecte des spécialités d'autres cfa2
d'autres spécialités à la prise en
charge de patients que vous nommez
l'hôpital aujourd'hui n'ont pas
fonctionné comme ça durablement alors il
y en a eu moins en octobre qui allait au
printemps il est énormément au printemps
mais parce que je redis au printemps on
est dans la sidération d'un nouveau
virus donc on sait tous mobilisés tous
les hospitaliers tous les hôpitaux de
france même ceux à la rigueur qui était
moins touché par le virus et qui
finalement bon at on attendu des
patients qui ne sont jamais venus tant
mieux mais avait s'étaient mobilisés
prêts à recevoir il y avait vidé
effectivement les plannings hospitalier
ce qui fait qu'on a énormément des
programmes et on l'a moins fait en
octobre novembre
tant mieux et en ce moment où on va on
commença à des programmes et on
recommence à des programmes et je vous
donne un seul exemple mon hôpital à
fontainebleau
on a aujourd'hui 132 patients qu'ovide
pris en charge à l'hôpital au plus fort
de la delà de la gare de la de
l'épidémie au mois d'avril
on était monté à 96 donc oui alors on a
moins de réanimation propose honda on a
à peine 10 de ces patients qui sont en
réanimation là où on est monté jusqu'à
une trentaine
donc on voit bien que la prise en charge
a changé de nature
on met moins les gens en réanimation
tant mieux parce que c'est quand même un
peu dur d'être en réanimation enfin les
on met souvent comme a enfin bon c'est
une technique très très invasive et et
qui peut laisser des séquelles mais la
pression sur les lignes hospitalière
elle est plus forte aujourd'hui en tout
cas dans mon hôpital qu'elle l'était au
mois d'avril parce qu'il ya beaucoup
plus de patients qui en avait au mois
d'avril
donc ça veut dire pour laisser 132 lits
on n'a pas de service qu'ovide à
l'hôpital a donc ça veut dire qu'on les
a on les prend ailleurs
on les prend sur d'autres services condé
programmé confites d'autres services
donc à des gens qui ont des opérations -
moins urgente
on leur dit revenez dans quelques
semaines en quelques mois on parle
évidemment si on combine mais on imagine
qu'il ya du personnel aussi qui est
atteint par locaux vides du personnel
soignant est sur des hôpitaux qui ne
peuvent tourner parce qu'il ya un trop
grand nombre de personnels soignants qui
est atteint par le cos vide et est ce
que ces gens là on leur demande de venir
travailler parce que sinon il ya une
trop grande pénurie de personnel ça a
été le cas déjà au printemps il c'est
toujours le cas c'est à dire
effectivement faux faux faux faut avoir
l'honnêteté de le dire
les patients des personnels que vie des
agents ont touché par la maladie qui ne
développe pas de forme grave de on peut
être amené à leur demander effectivement
de continuer à travailler
ils sont de toutes façons protégés ils
sont de toute façon voilà je pense que
ce sont aussi des professionnels de
l'hygiène de la protection ils sont
formés pour ça mais effectivement il ya
des hôpitaux on l'a vu à dieppe
on l'a vu à compiègne on le voit parfois
dans certains ehpad où vous avez les
mini clusters et vous avez des dizaines
d'agents qui tout d'un coup sont touchés
alors on a pas d'hopital qui ferment et
on n'aura jamais d'hôpital qu'il ferme
on a des hôpitaux qui fonctionnent en
rappelant les gens en en bousculant les
calendriers de vacances en faisant
baisser les gens beaucoup plus qu'il ne
devrait sans doute mais un moment
nécessité fait loi il faut faire face et
le drame enfin le drame à la réalité
plutôt c'est que ça fonctionne comme ça
depuis le printemps
je vois moi j'étais dans ma foi je suis
allé dans le mode dans les services de
mon d'hôpital j'ai croisé une une
soignante c'était juste au lendemain du
1er janvier elle était contente parce
qu'elle elle partait le lendemain matin
en vacances elle avait annulé ses
vacances de pâques
elle avait annulé ses vacances ses
vacances d'été à l'est près juste un
grand week-end elle va annuler ses
vacances de la toussaint et entre noël
et le jour de l'an comme ya beaucoup
d'activités l ai pas pris de vacances
elle partait une semaine chez elle parce
que en janvier y avait pas tellement
destinations lointaines en vacances mais
voyez donc s et les étables et
satisfaite et de la progression
salariale qui lui a été proposé bien sûr
c'est un vrai plus pour il faut
reconnaître à ce gouvernement d'avoir
effectivement sur le volet des
rémunérations fait un vrai fort 8
milliards d'euros 7 milliards pour
l'hôpital dire ça ça n'est pas ça ce
n'est pas rien donc il ya eu
effectivement un vrai geste sur les
rémunérations il ya eu aussi un vrai
geste qui est moins visible sur le
déroulement des carrières on est dans la
fonction publique il ya des grilles
voilà pour un pour avancer sa carrière
des grilles statutaire il ya des choses
qui ont été faites qui effectivement
améliore la progression des carrières
donc il ya eu de ce point de vue là un
vrai geste maintenant ça c'est la
colonne des plus la colonne des moins
pour puisque vous évoquez des accords du
ségur c'est qu'on n'a pas du tout touché
à ce qui était pourtant une promesse du
président de la république c'est à dire
le fonctionnement du système de santé
la bureaucratisation extrême de ce
système de santé voilà et que ça ça
reste un sujet qui a acquis qui doit
être et qui sera qui sera examiné un
jours merci beaucoup merci fans avec van
persie venu nous voir et nous avoir
éclairé sur la situation des hôpitaux
aujourd'hui merci je rappelle que vous
êtes maire de fontainebleau président de
la fédération hospitalière de france
fabrice avant de se quitter on regarde
la une du dauphiné libéré et ce sont ces
deux femmes qui ont été tués hier en
gros marre des shs et oui le drame d'une
situation d'une conjoncture aussi la
perte d'emploi voilà voilà victime c'est
une transe rabatteurs triaire c'est la
question posée à la une du dauphiné
libéré merci beaucoup merci on passe
ensuite au club des territoires
la mutuelle nationale territoriale la
mutuelle des agents des services publics
d'eau
[Musique]